foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
all I ever wanted to do is be a racer
I'm doing it
the 10 of you are the best
Grand tourism
or is your chance to race real cars
the guys who race are Elite athletes
your kids are scrawny little gamer kids
that's where you come in
you think you can do the impossible I'm
here to prove that you can't
everything
you puked on my lawn I know what I'm
doing not a face I've raced this track a
thousand times in the game let me drive
it my way
that was actually pretty great
we have a newcomer this year his
presence is shaking the foundation of
the sport this is the major leagues the
other driver your pit crew are going to
hate you much easier with a joystick
isn't it
see anything
I'm not sure if I can do this most
people can't
I got a feeling you're not most people
if I lose I lose more than just a Race
So I'm not gonna quit we've got to prove
to everyone
alone
erased it what like a thousand times now
you just gotta do in real life
Gran Turismo based on a true story
[Music]